Hi everybody,
um, happy Thursday, unofficial
last day of reinvent. How y'all doing?
OK, alright, that's the energy. OK,
I was actually watching some of the talks that like my
coworkers presented on like Monday morning at
8 o'clock and there's nothing, there was
silence, um, that was so devastating
for me to watch. This will not be like that. We are
friends up here and we're gonna go on a
journey today through infrastructure's code
and governance and it's gonna be very fun.
Um, but before we get into all of
that, I do have some questions for you all
because this is an us situation. This
is not a breakout session. They won't let me do those
anymore. Um, this is a us session,
so like if you have any questions at any time,
you just say David
Sefi, and we'll be like, what's up?
Um, speaking of David, I'm
David. Uh, my name is David Kilman. I'm a principal
engineer in AWS,
specifically infrastructures code, so
things like. Um,
cloud formation and terraform and
CDK, a quick survey,
who here uses infrastructure as code?
Oh, that is a beautiful 100%
um, maybe I, we actually can't
see up here because of the light, so I, I will,
the narrative will be changed to suit
the talk, um,
uh, a quick survey who uses cloud formation?
OK, I see you, I see you.
Uh, who's this terraform?
Nice. Who uses both?
Oh yeah, I like this guy. Um,
cool. Oh, any Plumi? Any,
any Plumi people? They have the best swag at
the, that's why I ask. OK, anyway, um, so
my name is David Kilman. I am a senior, uh, principal
engineer on cloud formation, and today we're talking
about, um,
infrastructures code governance, making
deployments of IAC safe, um,
and, uh, I am joined today byefi.
This is my friend.
Hi, nice to meet you all. I'm Sefi Abrech. I'm
a senior solution architect.
I'm working with governance
and compliance and security. This is
the side that I'm covering here,
and let's get started.
OK, so we're all familiar with
this uh uh pattern. You write
in some code, write
some cloud formation, some terraform,
you push it to your gate,
and then there is the CICD pipeline
that start running, right? And you have
your resources deployed
inside your AWS account.
We're all familiar with it, right?
This is how we work.
Great. But
uh
How do we implement some gutters
around this situation? And this is what we're going
to talk about today. We will run
this slide, so we go to the codes
directly.
Um, so developers are moving very fast,
right? You all use, I believe, generative
AI to generate code to help
you with the infrastructure.
And we need something to help
you stay in the guards of
your organization, the security
requirements, cost requirements,
even
machines image requirements.
So let's see if the car is working.
This took us like a few hours to put together.
It's working. Inside
the garble. Yeah, please hold the applause until the end.
So,
what we're going this is the one in
cloud formation hooks
is coming to help us,
huh? 00
dude. It's
so good we want to show you twice. You make it so good.
Ah, yeah,
see what automation don't do
cops do. So on
the left side, on the right side, you see
the simple cloud formation template to
going to create a resource.
And it's going to be failed,
OK, it's going to be failed because it's not,
uh, a stand
in the organizational requirements,
OK. And now I'm passing to David.
Well, give you some use cases. Cool. So whenever
we talk about failing things, Sefi always,
uh, sends it back to me, um, so,
uh,
yeah, today we're gonna talk about infrastructure as
code and like how proactive controls
can stop bad things from happening.
Um,
so we're gonna talk about hooks. Uh, hooks,
hooks is a cloud formation feature. Um, I
work on cloud formation. They sign all of my
paychecks, um,
but we also realized that like infrastructure's
code spans beyond just cloud formation.
So we're also gonna talk about terraform, um, in
a bit. So,
uh, for the first part of this talk we're gonna do a lot of demos
in cloud formation, but Steffi's gonna show you how
things work in terraform as well. I just, um,
I, anytime I type.
For terraform apply on my Amazon
issued laptop. It like lights on fire.
So, um, Sefi will be doing the terraform
stuff, but,
uh, the,
the root of it is like proactive controls are the
same across all of IAC, right? And like
what are proactive controls for, um,
you know, I think probably the most common
and like most important reason we talk about
proactive controls is around things like
safety and governance,
um. And we wanna stop bad
things from happening basically, right? So if
you look at this slide, it's like a really simple slide,
right? Um, I have a, this is on the left is a
cloud formation template and this is the simplest
cloud formation template I could write. It just creates an
S3 bucket,
um. And on the right you can
see that like if I tried to provision this
bucket it actually fails because uh
there's no bucket encryption enabled
and that's totally fine right like
I think uh
quick question for the audience like who who here
considers themselves like security people like
security is part of my responsibility cool um
who how about platforming people like the
platform team? OK cool yeah
so right like we see this a lot like
I'm an engineer and I don't know if you can. Intel
like I kind of just do stuff very fast.
I basically try to find the fastest
way to make things work, um, and I
don't always think about the platform.
Um, I always think about security, but
sometimes I omit security in the name of speed,
uh, like this bucket,
uh, I think like all of us in like security
and like platforming teams are familiar with like
this trade off, right? Like
developers wanna go really fast but
like we who own the platform or get paid
for security incidents. Don't wanna sacrifice
like the platform security or
like governance or like compliance,
you know, we
tons of organizations have things like FedRAM
compliance or like NIS compliance, all these like
compliance packs which require you to be
like always put on bucket encryption
or like enable object lock on your S
Suite bucket, right? Like these are kind of like really nuanced
like configuration options that we don't really
wanna have to have that conversation with developers
every time they wanna create an S Suite bucket
that um.
They have to turn on SSE encryption
for their bucket, right?
We wanna make sure that they can move fast but
like not break our platform.
So hooks and like proactive controls
help stop bad things from happening
before they happen.
Um, I, I'm gonna tell you a story. We're
gonna have a lot of stories and they're all gonna be a little embarrassing
about me, um, or our interns, uh, but,
uh, a long time ago, does anyone
remember, um, when Lambda launched
Function Endpoints,
uh, a long time, it, it was like maybe 2 or 3 years
ago, uh. Um,
does anyone here not know what lambda is? It's totally fine.
Do we count our lambda? OK, cool. Uh, I love
lambda. Um, any time reinvent
is very fun for us as well because this is the first
time we're hearing a lot about a lot of new features.
Um, so I remember a few years ago at Reinvent Lambda
launched this feature called Function Endpoints.
It basically lets you like generate an HTP
URL that when someone calls it, like
sends a get request to it or a post request or something,
it invokes a lambda function, and I thought
this was super cool and it was like really easy
to set up, um.
And this was sort of back before things like hooks
existed,
uh, and so I was, uh,
I was experimenting. I was writing, I was
trying to like set up this like lambda, uh,
with the function endpoint, and it was actually really fun.
I had it like the lambda function send
a like a text message to my manager
saying that you should give David a raise, um,
and then I posted the URL into like our,
our organizations Slack channel and everyone kept cooking. It was,
it was really a beautiful day,
um, but it was really fun for me because I got. Like, experiment
with this new feature. I had a lot of fun with it.
Um, the cool thing about function endpoints is that there's
also a lot of configuration that you can do
for security. You can say,
hey, like only like this IP
address range can call this endpoint or like
it has to be within this like VPC and
it's private. Um, those are really cool
and I did not care about them, uh,
because like I just wanted to get it to work. I wanted to make
a funny like joke for my coworkers and
send like this link out,
um, so I did that. And it was fun and then I was
going home. I was going home, uh,
and I was on the train like
listening to, I don't know, some podcast or something
and like I got this like, like my, I thought,
I thought it was like an amber alert, but I
was actually getting paged and I was like this is
what I'm not, I am not on call. Why am I getting
paged
and it turns out like our we had this
reactor, uh, detective control
system that like scanned our AWS accounts
every hour or so to make sure
that like all of our. Resources were compliant
and it turns out like our security
team um had decided that like
a
globally accessible function endpoint
that costs money when it is invoked
that's just accessible by anyone was
not compliant with security um
so I, I had to like get off the train and like
go find a coffee shop and like go
like read this ticket that I got paid
for and like go disable this
uh delete this function.
Um, I was really mad actually. This is the
thing that radicalized me on proactive controls. This
is why I care about it so much because I was
like, how did you just let me create something that
you knew was wrong, right?
So that's where proactive controls comes in
like that experience for
developers, it kind of sucks, right? Like
you page, like if you
create a resource and it is misconfigured
and you just let it happen
like that. Change can propagate through pipelines.
It can go to production, and reactive
controls and detective controls are amazing. They're like,
uh, they're a like
they always catch things, but proactive
controls are better because they can stop things
before they happen.
Um, so that's why I love, um,
uh, proactive controls, and, uh, that was just
a long story to say that proactive controls are really
good for governance,
um. Another thing that
proactive controls are really helpful for are
stopping you from making accidental mistakes,
um. This, so in this example
I have, um, uh, a,
uh, cloud formation template with an auto scaling
group, uh, and my auto scaling group had
a minimum of 1 EC2 instance
and a maximum of 100
EC2 instances,
um, so in, in cloud formation you can create
this thing called a change set which is very similar to
a terraform plan which basically just says
hey I'm transitioning from like this state
to this other state,
um. So, uh, in
this case I had a hook that was running
that when I tried to make this change, uh,
failed. It failed because the hook had
logic in it that said, hey, whenever
some sort of like capacity change
happens on a bunch of resources so like CPU,
memory, I ops, um,
like auto scaling group sizes, whenever those
changes happen and they exceed
50%,
I'm just gonna fail, right, because this is product.
Like you're changing things really drastically,
uh, so
in this example it actually wasn't me. I didn't
make the change. I'm not the villain of this particular
story. We had an intern. This intern
was so smart and much smarter than me,
um, and one of the things that our intern
was doing was he, they really wanted to like
deploy our service to their
own like we give all developers
at Amazon, they get an AWS account that they can
do anything with,
um, so. Wanted to deploy our service to
their um their own personal account and
I was so excited because I was like yay bias for action
this is fun you're gonna experiment
um and this intern also was like very frugal
they're like I don't need 100 EC2
instances being spun up in my account so
they actually changed, they changed their
template, um, to make it so that like
the number of auto scaling, um, the EC2
instances that could be provisioned was 10 instead of 100.
Um, and through a series of,
uh, unfortunate accidents they
accidentally committed this change to our
repository and our pipeline picked it up
and our pipeline started to try to deploy it to our
beta stage and then that's when this hook
was invoked and stopped that change from rolling
out, which is great because if our service,
um, you know, cloud formation powers like
100s of thousands of deployments,
um, so if we had only 10
EC2 instances to do that, that would have been a
very difficult day for our on call,
um. The other nice thing about,
um, uh, the thing I like about this
story is that, uh, Amazon has
like this culture called like COE
culture. Are folks familiar with COEs?
Um, they're just, uh, yeah, they're just basically
like when something goes wrong,
you're right, this doc that's like what went wrong?
Why did it go wrong,
and like most importantly, how do we stop it from happening
again. And the reason we had
this hook written for our team was
not because I'm really wise and a
wonderful platform engineer, um, and
uh foresaw this is because we had a
COE like a couple of years ago where
another intern had done something very similar.
So the nice thing about like our like COE
process is we have these tenants that are
actually. Items should not be best intentions,
right? So an easy action item is
like update a run book and that way when our
intern comes back they'll follow the
steps to make sure that they do the right thing.
We call those like good intentions and like
sometimes they're fine but we always are searching for
mechanisms like how can we enforce
that this bad thing does not happen again.
Um, so with things like hooks
you can take your learnings from different types of
outages like over eager interns
or maybe like careless engineers and
codify them and enforce them in your IAC
that way these mistakes don't have to happen again.
Um, OK, I'm gonna go over
one more use case that my manager
insisted I put in as a punishment.
Um, so the other great thing that
like proactive controls can do is make
sure that you don't spend too much money. Um,
sometimes engineers provision extremely
large EC2 instances because they're not responsible
for their AWS bill,
um, and they just leave them in their account and run
up huge bills. Um, that is. Something
I have done, so now we have a, a hook
on our team only
that makes sure that like there's a set of allow
listed, uh, EC2 instances
that we can deploy. Um, that's my manager
made me do that, um, because we had a huge bill,
but our actual practical reason
why folks would do this a lot is, you know,
uh, a lot of organizations do a lot of
negotiation with Amazon to make sure that we have
like savings plans or like certain
EC2. Instances that we get discounts on
and that's really hard information to like trickle
down to engineers or people who are building
platforms know that like hey you should only
use this particular type of instance
because we get a discount on it um so
that kind of information can be codified in
like a proactive control that says hey like
you didn't do anything wrong it's just that you tried to
like there's a better um instance
type that you can use uh that we get a
discount on. So part of controls
can help you with things like governance and security.
They can help codify best practices
and learnings from COEs.
They can help you, uh, make sure that
like trickle down, uh,
uh, organizational best practices like,
uh, cost, uh, best practices,
um, so they're really. Useful and they're kind of like
uh I think
they uh in in the IAC
world they're super valuable and I think
in cloud formation and Amazon specifically
like we're only just in the past couple of
years really like
understanding how valuable these are um so I'm
excited for us to like get together and experiment
with them. Cool,
uh, so you thought that it was cool
that I was talking for so long, uh, but now we're actually
gonna code because this is a code talk,
um, so in this code talk we're gonna do
a couple of things.
Uh, I'm gonna teach you a little bit about
cloud formation guard. This is our, our,
um. Policy is code DSL, um,
there's nothing really special about guard here.
Like you can replace it in your mind with, uh, any
policy has code language that you're familiar with like
Sentinel or Rego or like
check off, whatever you're comfortable with like conceptually
they all do the same thing.
Um, I'm gonna show you how to build a hook using
guard. Uh, we're going to go
through a beautiful journey of trying to deploy
a cloud formation stack, a process
that I'm sure we've all experienced and enjoyed a
lot, um,
and then I'm gonna show you how we cannot do
any of that and just use a couple of clicks to,
um, build a hook using something
called the control catalog.
Um, and of course, uh,
I will, we have, we're going to show you how to make it
work in terraform too, which is gonna be fun and
delightful, um,
but now we're actually gonna do all that
stuff, cool,
so, yeah,
switch. OK, I'm gonna assume
my official coding position
which is sitting on this chair with
my knees,
um, cool, uh,
yeah, let's get into it. Let's build stuff. OK,
so also this Amazon has
this thing called connections where every day they ask us a
question and you cannot stop it from happening and it always
pops up during
presentations so I'm gonna move this over
here and we're just not gonna talk about it anymore.
OK, cool, so let's set up some proactive
controls for IAC and show how they work.
All right, so let's go to cloud formation.
Which is my favorite, uh, IAC
service that's natively hosted on AWS.
I talk a lot of smack about Terraform, but I actually
love it, so please don't take it personally.
Um, I'm gonna, uh, close every
single notification that came up because we are very
eager this year to open, uh, launch
a lot of features.
And I'm gonna go to our hook section.
So, um, this, this is our hooks page.
Uh, this is a, um, like
3 step picture that explains
in, uh, what I took 20 minutes
to explain. So this is always delightful if you
ever forget and don't feel like listening to this talk
again. Um, it just shows how, uh,
like a hook basically sits in front
of cloud formation doing something and evaluates
if that thing is good or bad. If it is bad,
it stops that bad thing from happening, um.
So I'm gonna actually go down here
and we're gonna create a hook
and we're gonna use guard because that's my DSL
of choice
and OK so over here
it tells us like hey you have to upload
your guard rules to S3.
Um,
and so this is a code talk, so I'm supposed to
be coding, but I'm remarkably
lazy, so we're not actually gonna write
these rules ourselves,
um, so there's this community on, on
GitHub, uh, of pre-written
guard rules, uh,
which are super cool. So I'm actually just gonna
go steal this from
our guard rules registry.
So this is GitHub. Uh, if
we go into the rules, you can see
that there's a bunch of different AWS services,
so like Amazon S3, this is one of my
favorite ones, so I'm gonna click it and you can see
that there's a bunch of different,
uh, uh, files that map
to a policy.
So we have S3 bucket default
block enabled, um,
S3 bucket logging is enabled,
uh, there, there's a bunch of, well, let's see what
is a good one?
Oh, bucket versioning enabled, that's
kind of fun. So, um, we're gonna just,
I, I already took a few of these, but I just wanted
to show you, um, there's a bunch of different
services over here.
Uh, let's see, IAM exists, which
is always a fun one,
and IM has a bunch of like IM is probably
the, the place where.
You can do the most damage from a security
point of view, um, so there's a lot of really fun
like, uh, oh,
policies written
already for IM, for example, no
admin access, uh, which
is, um, delightful we should
not have admin access for a lot of. Things,
um, so
you know, I,
what I did, uh, earlier for demo
magic purposes is I
cloned,
uh, this repository locally and I
took a couple of rules, um,
from that repository, so I have some Dynamo DB,
some IM, some lambda, some S3,
and I just zipped it up.
And then I uploaded it to S3.
Uh, we never know what the Wi Fi situation is
gonna be in these rooms, so I try to like pre-buffer
as much as, as much as I can.
So, um, I'm gonna go. I, I uploaded
my guard rules to S3 earlier,
so I'm gonna select this.
And I'm gonna tell guard to write
a bunch of logs whenever something fails,
and we're gonna call this something, um,
this is fun. Does anyone have a fun name for
this hook that we should call it? I'm thinking
very good hook. Does anyone have any other suggestions?
What? That,
that I don't know that I don't know what I expected from that. Uh,
I heard someone say, uh, uh,
I don't know, I heard gotcha hook. I like
that because it's like pew pew. I got you.
Um, so we're gonna call this the gotcha hook,
and hooks can run in a lot
of different places. So before a
cloud formation stack is updated,
uh, through cloud control API at change sets,
um, for this we're gonna just do resources.
We're gonna, so any time cloud formation goes to provision
a resource, it's gonna run these guard rules
to make sure that resource is compliant.
And I'm gonna tell um hooks
to run this whenever a resource is updated or
created.
And there's this thing called a hook mode. So
a hook, um,
I'm gonna change it to fail. So basically
any time this hook evaluates to false, it
blocks something. You can also put a hook and
warn mode so like a hook can fail
and it doesn't actually block something. So this is really
good if you're like authoring new rules and you wanna
test them out without necessarily blocking
people, um, but for this we're gonna block it
and I'm gonna create, uh, a new role
called the gotcha roll.
Um,
cool, um, you can tell, uh, you can
have hooks be really specific on exactly when
they run. I'm just gonna have it run all the time.
And I'm gonna create this hook.
Yay, cool. OK, so I created this up. It's
running in my account now. Um,
fun question,
uh, has anyone here used Gen
AI for IAC stuff yet?
OK, cool. Yeah, it's fun. It's fun. I
also use Gen AI for IAC stuff, uh,
for this talk.
I, uh, asked Kiro
to generate for me
a, um,
a, a template, a cloud formation template.
And I asked my prompt to Kira was basically
like I want a really simple cloud formation
template that creates a lambda function,
um, a Dynamo DB table, and an
S3 bucket, um, just to
create a really simple application that writes to Dynamo DB
and pulls files from S3.
And this is the this is the template
that it gave me,
um, it created a lambda execution
role. um, this is the role that lambda
will use to do stuff
um it created a lambda function, um,
so a simple inline function using
no JS
sure, I don't, that sounds good,
um, it created an S3 bucket with no properties
fine, that is a correct bucket.
And I created a Dynamo DB table
and the thing that I like about um this like
template that it generated is it tried a little
hard, right? Like it turned on a
point in time recovery for me which is a really
nice gesture. I do appreciate that
because um you don't wanna accidentally delete
your Dynamo DV table and realize you don't have
a point in time recovery. Turned on, so, um,
this, this is a great template, uh, and I
think maybe as I was scrolling
through this, the security people may have lifted
an eyebrow or, or maybe folks
realized, um, that I was alluding to certain things
earlier with this S3 bucket, but, uh,
I'm, we're gonna, we're gonna try to deploy it to cloud
formation and see what happens now.
So I'm going to go take
this template.
Uh,
cloth from the web,
oops,
sorry. Cohoon
next. Uh
Yeah. Oops, sorry.
I don't, um,
sometimes the, um,
uh, the AI doesn't always
create perfectly valid cloud formation.
OK, so that one works. OK, we're gonna
call this, this will probably
work.
Um, and I'm going
to
just power through all these
prompts and tell it to do stuff
and it's gonna start creating stuff.
Oh, does anyone have any feedback for cloud formation?
Um, we'll get to that later. We love feedback.
OK, cool. Uh, so, uh, cloudformation tried
to create my stack, my dynamoji B
table, and it failed.
So if I scroll through like all of like
what happened chronologically.
Is, uh, it, it started to, it started
creating this lambdaro estuary bucket,
um, but before it did
anything like actually called the like service APIs
to create a bucket or create a lambda function, it
invoked our gotcha hook,
um,
and as you can see,
um, like the estuary bucket failed
to create because the gotcha hook
failed. So if I click on this
we can see that, oh, this hook failed with the message
that the template, um.
Uh, you know, we had a rule called S3 bucket
lock enabled that failed, a
rule called S3 bucket read prohibited
that failed. Um,
so, and I guess we're gonna have to fix that.
So if I go into like the hook, you
can see like,
all right, here's the details of this particular hook
run. Um, I had a bunch of, you know, we
had the lambda rules, uh, rules,
and the dynamo DB rule and the IM rules. They
did not run because this is an S3 bucket, but the
S3 ones did.
And I'm gonna click this S3 bucket lock
enabled uh real quick and
um it kind of gives us uh it tells
us exactly what went wrong, right? So
it says the check was not compliant because
the property um
of S3 bucket properties
object lock is missing
and we have this little helpful hint saying
hey like the violation is
that S3 um bucket object lock
was not set
and we should set it to true uh to make this
check pass.
So just to um
I'm gonna show you how what this rule looks
like let me see.
Oh yeah, so here it is,
um, so this is a guard rule, um,
so this is all comments, but
it's just, uh, this is describing what this rule
does. So this is my object lock enabled
rule, uh,
and what this does is it, uh, every
time this rule runs it takes,
uh, as input the cloud formation resource
that's getting provisioned.
And we say this rule applies if
any resource type
is of AWSS3 bucket.
And our rule says that you know
S3 bucket default lock must be enabled
and it says when it has found uh a resource
of type S3 bucket.
Assert that
there is a property called object block enabled
and that the property object block enabled
equals true,
right? And you can see in this like guard rule
I have this like free form text here it says
like violation hey like
if we get here that means that the object
lock enabled property did not
exist
um and it needs to so we can set this feedback.
And if the um
S3 bucket lock
enabled existed but was not true
we say hey you have to set this to true and
you can see like this is the data
that pops up right here so
it it's you can be as specific
or as like cryptic as you'd like
to be with your. Feedback, but this
is a really good example that I think this is really good feedback
for me, um, because it's really
clear what happens. It's looking for this object lock
enabled property
and it look is looking for it to be true.
So let's go back to our template and help
Kiro a little bit. So I'm gonna
add a property
called object lock enabled, and it says it
should be true.
I don't know what object lock enabled means, but
my platform administrator, who was very wise,
said that we needed it. So I'll believe them,
um. Actually I do know what object locked
enabled is, but it is very cool. So
like if you, it's, uh,
it's really an interesting feature, but, um,
critically,
um, that I'm putting my platform hat on now, like
you can only enable object lock,
uh, on S3 buckets when you're creating the bucket.
So this is actually a really good rule because you cannot
add that feature
after the fact. So,
um, we're gonna create it, we're gonna try creating the
stack again with my new, new
and improved template.
And we're gonna call it
This Will Death Work.
Um, you can see that I go through this
experience pretty often,
um, so I'm gonna, I'm just gonna power
through the cloud formation console
and we're gonna say submit.
And we're gonna see again what's happened.
Oh, it failed. OK,
uh, this is not too surprising. We knew some things were gonna
fail, but I just wanted to see what, what
it looked like now.
So if we go back to our, our hook,
um, you can see now our, our S3 bucket
default lock enabled experience worked.
Uh, it, it was fixed,
um, and it passed, but we still have this
other rule that failed called S3 bucket
read prohibited,
and if I look at this one, it's a little more complicated,
so it's saying, um.
Uh, like, it was looking for this property
called public access block configuration
and the properties of this estuary bucket,
um, and you know
there's, there's a couple of properties it wanted
to be set, so like block public ACLs,
block public policy, ignore public ACLs,
restrict public bucket access. It wanted
all of those to be true,
so, um, I think.
Buckets being public is bad,
um, in general,
so we were like I think as the platform teams
and security folks we are always
really excited when folks wanna make sure
that their buckets
can have
absolutely no way of having public
access, um, so by setting all of these
values, uh, we can, uh,
uh, it's true
we can make that a reality. So
let's go back to our little SU bucket
or I have this public.
Block public access block configuration.
I'm just gonna like
say tell that I'm just gonna
copy straight from this
output.
Uh Boop
boop boop And
I'm gonna say
true. Alright,
cool, so I did that.
That was fun, um, and I'm sure you all
were really excited for me to go through the create wizard
again, but
we know there's more things that failed, right?
Like if I go back to our template.
You know, the Dynamo DB table failed.
The lambda execution role failed. You
know, let's see,
uh, Dynamo D B
Dynamo DB table failed because table
must be encrypted.
So, um,
this is fun, and you know I enjoy
coding with you all, but
as a developer experience waiting
for my stack to create a
resource.
And then iteratively trying to fix it
is not great, right? Like I
think this, this, this stack is really fun
because it's serverless. It's using Dynamo, it's S3,
it's really fast.
But if I was using something like ECS,
which like when you create an ECS service
in cloud formation, it waits for the deployment
to actually be done
before it like considers the resource successfully created,
that can take a while that can. Take a few minutes if
you're creating a cloud front distribution like that
also can take minutes so your your
stack execution time like
can take a while and you don't
really wanna find out that you're the
template that you're building
was not compliant
only after like uh minutes like 20-30
minutes um
we wanna know early as early as possible.
So, um,
this is fun. Instead of going
through, um.
And like iterating on this template one by
one trying to fix all these errors I'm gonna
show you a fun trick.
So we're gonna go back to our hook, our
gotcha hook, that was a really good name. I don't know who
said that, but you should consider yourself really cool,
um, so I'm gonna go to our hook,
and you can see like for this hook you can see
all the different times it ran,
um, and like when it ran, so
it, you know, it ran for this old stack,
ran for this new stack,
um, you can also see if it failed
or not, you know,
oh, they all failed,
um, surprise, uh, but I'm gonna have the, I'm
gonna change.
This hook to
actually run not just when we create resources
but when we create a change set,
um, so are folks here familiar with change sets?
Raise your hand if you know what they are. Cool,
um, change sets are basically cloud formation's
version of like a terraform plan we I'll,
I'll show you about that than just describe it. I'll
show you how it works,
um. So I'm gonna go to cloud
formation. I'm gonna upload my template.
And
Uh,
change sets rule.
And OK,
so instead of clicking submit and having cloud formation
go try to provision everything,
I'm gonna create a change set,
and this change set will show me like, hey, here
are all the things that would happen if you tried
to apply that. So this change that says,
hey, like if you tried to apply this change
set, you're gonna create a dynamoDB table, lambda
execution rule, lambda function,
um, but my lambda, my
change set is actually in a failed state
because
my hook failed, my, um,
my gotcha hook failed, right, so.
This time what's cool about like this
experience is that you get
every single one of the thing
like the rules that I ran like they run
early
and you can see all the details of how to fix
this stuff um directly.
So if I go back to my gotcha hook,
you know, I can look at this,
this hook rum,
and you can see like, well, look, we fixed a bunch of stuff, we
fixed the public read prohibited and we fixed the
object lock,
but now you can see in one place like, hey, like
your Dynamo DB table has to have SSE
enabled
and your IM,
uh, uh,
I have a role with an admin policy, and
the fix for that is
remove it, uh, which makes a lot of sense,
so. Uh, just for
fun, we're going to, I'm going
to show you,
uh, we're gonna.
Through the power of movie magic, I've
already fixed all of this actually,
and I'll just show you
ta da.
How it works.
Yeah. What happens in the delightful
case? I'll show you.
Cool.
Yeah, so in this case you can see that my change set
can actually run. I can execute it.
You can see that, um, our hook
passed because we, we fixed it
and it was truly delightful.
Um, so that's kind of like the experience
that I have as like a, a team lead of
writing, um,
um, confirmation guard to make sure things
work. I wanna show you one more thing real
quick because confirmation guard is really cool,
but not everyone wants to do it.
Um, we have another hook called
the control catalog,
and this is meant, um,
for like,
uh, compliance checks.
So if you look, uh,
if we look at,
uh,
this basically has a bunch of like.
Rebuilt, um, policies,
uh, so I can, oh see, I
can just, so instead of having to write the guard
myself, Amazon owns and
runs these rules so we maintain them, um,
I can basically say hey, like this bucket
has to have S3 enabled. I'm versioning enabled.
Uh, it has to have server side encryption,
and Steffi's gonna show you more about this later,
but what's really cool about this is that like
these policies are also grouped
by like their compliance framework, right?
So I was talking about NIST earlier so
you can see like oh this rule
is, um, part like
applies to the NIST framework, uh,
and you know I'm super
excited about security so I could just create this hook
with all of these, um.
Uh, uh, proactive controls already
enabled and I don't have to write a single
line of code, right? Like you can take this home,
uh, and just enable this hook in
one mode with all these controls turned on
and see like, oh,
what resources are people in my
organization creating which are not compliant,
um, and also if you, if you walk in in
a multi uh accounts environment
you can run it on all accounts.
How many of you are walking with multi-account environment
from secure perspective?
How many of you implement control tower?
Oh cool. So after I we show
some cool stuff, yeah, yeah,
uh, so this is delightful that I'll create this hook. It'll
be in my account and I can play with it and experiment
with it, but in reality, like Steffi's saying, like
you really actually wanna make like apply
this to OUs and like enforce
it, um,
so he'll show you how to do that later.
Um, also, uh, you
know, I love terraform and
I've been talking a lot, so I'm actually gonna hand it over
to Sefi to show you how this can
work, uh, how you can use conservation hooks,
uh, to also run policy and practiceive
controls for terraform.
Yeah, thank you, David. You're welcome.
Let's just fix the credentials.
What's up?
Oh
I don't want to run
for for. Just
seems like what I want.
Yes,
so yeah, the question is like why not just
have hooks always run on change sets, is
that right? Basically,
yeah, that's a really good question. There is nuance,
um, so when we run at the resource level
we're literally about to call the APIs so we have
every piece of information that we
need to call the APIs
at the change set time there are dynamic
values that we don't necessarily know
so you don't always have all the information
that you need like that you would
need to make a
fully deterministic decision.
Um, so an example would be like
I need the subnet, uh, you're
running, um, you're creating a, uh,
RDS instance
you wanna look at the, uh, subnet
IDs and evaluate to make sure that they're,
um, correct, um, like allowed,
uh, if your cloud
formation template references the subnet
ID as an output of like the subnet
resource, there's no way like you can know that
until you create the resource.
Um, so basically like the,
it's, it's sort of like a filter you have
less information at changed that
time because um.
Properties that are only evaluated after a
resource is created are not available yet
because you've not created the resource,
um, but at resource time
you have all the information so usually
like for our hooks we generate, uh, we run
them on both and we usually write our rules
such that like if the value just isn't present
because it's like not, uh, because it
hasn't been resolved yet we just skip it.
So and that's why I.
Why Jean said
not that certain values cannot be elaborate
at this time.
Just seems to
Yes. Yes.
But that's what I'm saying.
Oh yeah, I mean that's fair. Uh, I think, um,
we just like Chances is
like Chances hook launched last year
and so like we don't have like a super opinionated
approach yet with like the wizard. It's just,
but it's like a fair point. Like I think if
I were to create a hook, like the defaults would be like
resources and change sets, um,
the reason why like some. Sometimes we don't
make that is because like Steffi will show you that like
like we're gonna apply this to terraform now and Terraform
doesn't have change sets so like
it's a good point, yeah, like I think for most
if you're using cloud formation I would almost always just
choose all of the things so like resources stack
change set so good
oh. A Party
Ah, OK, so this, the question is like how
do, what do I do with exceptions basically?
There's a few things you can do with exception, so I, I
skipped through the hook creation screen like pretty
quickly, but in there you can basically
exempt certain stacks, um,
you can just say, you know what, this is fine.
Uh, the other thing that I didn't show you
is that in the guard hook, um, you
can provide this thing called like an input parameter
which is, um, like, so a common thing that
we see is basically like,
um, like this stack
and this particular bucket are exempt
and so what you would do is like you would put
that into like a, a file, put it in S3,
and then you tell your guard hook to like
read that file and then that data
becomes like available um as
uh. Uh, like context to write your
rules. Another thing is if you look at the guard
repository,
if there are rules that you think are like useful
but like developers should be able to override them
themselves if they think, if you look at the guard repository,
basically like you can, you can include
additional metadata in the cloud formation template,
uh, at the top being like I acknowledge this but
I don't care and like you can write
your rules such that like it's like, OK, as
long if there's like a suppression rule in the template
I'll skip this rule, but it's up to you, but yeah.
Good good question. Uh, was there another question over there?
Oh cool
I had stated that um there's some certain clients.
Yes, uh, so terraform plan
is like almost exactly equivalent
to, uh, chain sets.
The weird thing with terraform plans is like we don't
actually like that's on the client side, so
we have no interception point for that so we
can't apply hooks at that level,
um, so we can do it with
resources in terraform because we have the AWS cloud
control provider which basically just takes.
Yeah, yeah, and Steffi's gonna show you that right now,
so I won't show you. David, you will help me.
Yeah, yeah. So, uh,
before we start, I will, uh, run tele from
apply and we're going to fail, OK,
everybody relax. We're going to fail. This is one of
the reasons we're doing it.
And then we start walking.
So I have two rules.
If you saw the template of David
before of the cloud formation template for
the lambda,
you use the deprecated runtime.
I think not 16 because he will create it for you.
So basically I created some guards that
check exactly
which run time is inside the resource
because you don't want to run deprecated
run time. And you
see that uh as David mentioned, we use
resource type AWS lambda function, and
then we take the runtime variables, but
from where we take it.
We take it from the cloud formation
template reference.
Are you familiar with that? Who is working with
the cloud formation?
Yeah, so, also in the, in
the rules, you can see which variables you
can take from it
and then just paste it inside the
rule. For example, you can see all the version of
the lambda.
But now that the telephone is running,
I want to see, to show you how we're going to use the AWCC
to create the hook.
OK? So we'll do it really fast.
We're going to create a hook
with guard.
OK,
let me browse
the file that I zipped before.
OK, and I'm going to use the same bucket
for the results also.
And of course the name, but in
the hook target we're going to use the control
cloud control APIs,
OK, which basically is going to catch the telephone
uh applies that we're doing
and it is exactly the same thing like cloud formation
nos we can, uh, choose what action we want,
create, update, etc. and
we can choose if we want to warn or fail.
OK, so I already created one of the hooks.
Now let's see
what happened to our telephone.
Oh
OK, so basically what we did here.
Uh, I also use QO to
generate it.
OK, we're going to use uh to try to create
a lambda
with run time.
Of
no DS 18,
which is deprecated.
And also we're going to
try to deploy an F3 with
a lot of missing variables
like block public access, bucket encryption,
etc.
Now there is something new.
My skin is a little bit big for me.
It's OK. You can see like this.
You can see that uh uh
also in the telephone in the ID
you can see the reason
of why the hook fail you.
OK, for example, in the
S3 bucket you can see that it's failed because
S3 encryption required
S3 no public read in S3 version enabled
like David show before in the you can see
through the ID, but
if I want to see the
exact reason all the output of
the souk of what happened.
So I can just take
Yes, Jason.
Add
a kind of a dash and then it will be to my STD
out over here.
OK,
so if I'm a developer, I can use it
for my VS code, and if I'm a click ops
guy, I can use it for theUI,
right.
OK.
Uh,
what is we want to see?
Just to show you from here also.
You see, it's exactly the same like the like the cloud
formation looks. It's working the same with styrofoam.
Right? OK.
Basically this is a demo of.
Yeah, the, the cool thing, so
Sefi used the AWSCC provider
which is different from the AWS provider.
Um, with the AWSCC provider,
um, basically like, uh,
it uses cloud control API under the hood, so
it takes the resource and it sends it to cloud
formation to create it rather than
orchestrating API calls directly on the client
side like the AWS provider
since we can do since like it sends the
entire payload to us before it gets created,
that's why hooks can run at the same time,
um, that's why you can catch it before, yep,
exactly. So we want to show now
of how to implement it on
organization unit, yeah,
um, so any, any questions about the terraform
implementation.
Oh yeah, can you show the provider?
What do you mean provider? Um, yeah.
Yeah, so the required provider here is Hashi
Corp AWSWCC, yeah,
instead of AWS.
This is a different because as David
mentioned we want to uh catch it
before it create a release resource so it's not
doing telephone
uh API calls
straight to the AWS account. It's
it's sending the payload and then you can
block it before it's happened.
Yeah, basically all of these hooks
is if we start this talk
when we talk about it, it's to
uh.
Stop people to get call after
hours because they create something that
they didn't supposed to create and they didn't
even know that they're supposed
to do it that way. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
right?
Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Right, so this is not a
drop-in replacement if you have existing terraform
and you're using AWS,
the AWS provider. Hooks is not very
helpful for you
going forward. Um, so our relationship
with Hashy Corp is, uh, like the
Hashy Corp owns this provider, but
like it's a partnership with us,
um, and
one of the main reasons why like we partnered with Hashi
to create this is not for hooks at all. That's just
like a nice side effect,
but mostly around like coverage. So,
um, we, we've noticed.
Um, and our customers have noticed that like
new feature launches and, um,
and terraform
like can be
like they can lag, uh they can get there
before AWS support, uh, AWS
and confirmation support resources,
but we've noticed a lot with like AWS we
have like mandates on like launching with
resource support immediately, um, that
there's like this growing gap of sort of like
medium to like lower popular
resources and terraform just never getting
like support.
Um, and so to like help with that we
basically said hey like yes use AWS
provider for stuff if you want, but also you have
access to the cloud formation versions as well
so you can mix and match but, uh,
and like a side effect of that is that
with hooks you can also intercept like
governancey stuff with that.
But yes, to your point, like there's not a
lot of sugar coating on that if you're using the AWS
provider. Later today,
um, there we can't, um,
put hooks in that call path. The
only option you have really is sort of like IM
and like SCPs to do, uh,
gov governancey stuff, but those are
RCPs, clarative policies. There's a
lot of options that you can do it in the
organization level through control tower
to block from this thing to happen,
uh, but
yeah. Cool,
cool, uh, one more question, yeah.
got Yes, yes,
yes, change sets, uh, change sets
and hooks and the control
hook and lambda and guard hook, all those things are also
in GovCloud, uh,
the China regions and the secret regions
as well,
yeah, we're, uh, actually, um, we
had a really interesting launching cloud formation this,
uh, like last week or this week. I don't know what day it is, um,
where, uh, we do early validation, so
like basically. We'll check before a cloud
formation stack runs to make sure that
like the resources that you're trying to create don't
already exist or like some properties aren't
set correctly um it's sort of like
a developer experience thing but
it's built on top of hooks
so we're we're like
considered part of like launch blocking for news
for new region build so hooks and
like all of these features are there
um for all new regions.
Would you like to see how to implement the the
controls and hooks
on organization?
Yes. OK.
So, uh, we're going to
close all of this.
Uh,
so I have a multi-count strategy, a landing zone,
uh, in this, uh, demo environment, of course.
And we're going to, uh, get inside
to the management account.
It's up
and we will go to control towers.
Everybody familiar with control tower?
Yeah, cool.
And we will go to controlled catalog.
Just have a new face now, which is
amazing. And
we're going to filter the controls
proactive.
Behavior, OK.
And then we can choose
whatever we want.
Uh, any specific redshift.
Which is stuff.
And you can see exactly what framework like
David mentioned before, uh,
before, and
which regions are also uh deployed.
If you work in a region that this control is
not available, you cannot deploy it,
basically.
And we're going to do enable control.
And here we can uh uh
see also the selected control. You
can choose multiple controls.
You don't have to choose this one, just for this demo, choose
one, so it will be faster.
And then we have the organization units
that we can choose.
So let's take sandbox for example.
So I can just let me see that we have a
count over there for a second.
OK. box.
So we choose the OU we can target it and
we do enable controls.
It will take several seconds.
Until it will be provisioned, you can see all the
controls that I would implemented.
OK, we'll give it a second.
And the good thing about it that you can from
here you can choose
from a security perspective if you want
a specific framework and then you
can enable those controls. You
need to do it carefully because you do
want that
your team will succeed in this
stuff and
let's see if it's.
Yeah, we'll go to the account.
Reinvent. The cool thing about like
this approach versus the one I showed like I was
enabling the hook in like an individual account.
He's enabling it for like an entire OU
and like there's a like resource policy
on that hook that basically means you cannot turn it off
unless you are like the
in the um
uh root account.
So, OK, so you can see we have the guard
full governance that I built before and now we
have also the control tower hook.
That managed by control tower.
So under this OU I have
like 56, 10, 100
accounts. It's will implement to
all of these accounts and of course nobody can
be deleted
and that's where you can
secure your environment
from a management account.
The nice thing about the control catalog through control
tower too is that this talk is called from
like reactive to proactive. um,
the control tower catalog also
like it groups things by control
objective so like here's the thing like the
control objective that I wanna accomplish
like no public S3 buckets um
through the control catalog like you can enable
the proactive version of it but you can also
enable the reactive version, the detective
version too,
so it's like a defense. Depth thing like if someone
goes to the console like they're not going to get or
using the AWS provider in terraform
they're not going to hit hooks so you still probably
want detective controls as well. Basically
you want to implement all the
kinds of controls. It depends on the environment
and the security requirements, but what
I do want to show you here is that
you have common controls from control tower, of
course. It's also divide by
services. That means if you're using and
stuff like this
frameworks.
And uh uh and you can see
also uh which controllers are enabled
and this is also something cool to see
exactly uh on which accounts it's
enabled if you want to uh
I don't know invested how to say uh
like look yeah yeah if you wanna
look at like the impact that this is having
on like different accounts that you have which accounts
exactly and which framework also
which is also cool.
Yeah, any questions?
Oh. Increased from 100
deployable.
Uh, controls are the ones that are in.
It was like 50 back
From the quarter?
Yeah, did you open a sport case?
I, I think the, um, the, I,
I'm pretty sure that they use the same like
implementation of the control hook as
we have and we've completely rewrote it,
um, and so I'm pretty sure that that
limit is now gone um
we should double check to make sure yeah yeah
but we'll take it offline afterward and we'll take your
details, no problem, yeah, they, they had to rewrite
it basically for like uh
we, we wrote rewrote the implementation,
um, to support this, uh.
Because actually it was really funny, um, the hook,
the hook run times used to be constrained to like Java
and Python.
We added rust guard is written in rust.
All of these controls are written in GARD,
um, so we're able to like they were doing
truly gnarly things with the JVM in order
to like run rust, um, but we rewrote it and
now I think, um, probably a lot of these
limits are gone, but we should definitely double click for
that for you.
Any more questions?
Oh, there are a question in the back.
Pence confirmation versus.
Of course cloud formation, um,
just kidding, they're, they're paying my bills. I would say use,
use what's right for you and your
organization. I love, I think.
For for me for cloud
formation you get a lot of safety
and like auditability
built in if you have like if you're
using organizations um
and you like you have to manage an organization it's
really well integrated with that there's
a product called stack sets which basically you
can like provision
confirmation stacks across um
OEUs and accounts by default.
I would also say, and I,
I don't think this is a huge secret, so I don't mind telling you
that like most cloud formation customers
are also terraform customers, um,
so like a lot of shops just use what's right
for like the right thing,
yeah, and basically you also you have, uh,
if you want to multi
multi uh structure you have uh. The solution
of teleforms at the factory for telephone, which
is also very good, yeah,
but what you run into when you like
use terraform just from an AWS perspective
like I love terraform is that like
a lot of work that we do like hooks
like are like it's supported with an asterisk
so things like that sort of happen, um,
but uh yeah so.
Yeah. Also,
I love the CDK, so like I, I, HDL
is fine, but like I love the CDK and I love
like writing my code and um
type script so yeah.
Yeah Cool.
Any other questions y'all? Oh yeah.
Control to our site, you make a torn instead of failed.
It's a
wonderful idea. Uh, yeah, so, uh,
the technically, yes, uh,
and we're working with them to figure out like what the
right experience for that is.
I think some of that work is like, um,
under the, under the covers like the hooks
team has been doing some work on like.
Back port like um
sending invocation history backwards
to like the like root account
basically so like you can actually
do some observability on it and say like hey
like ok this is failing for 100%
of the accounts that it is deployed into
um so we're working with them to support that
so that's good.
pretty challenging from our side there's all the problems.
Yeah.
We had on warn right to see like what
the stats. Yes,
yeah, yeah, uh, I will show you one thing. So we did launch
some like, uh, like UX
improvements. It's, it's still not,
I, I will tell you two things about observability,
um. 100,
connections. Does anyone have any feedback for Amazon? Um,
uh, one is that, uh,
we don't talk about this much, but you can actually integrate,
uh, like there's an event
bridge
hook for hooks, so like you can create
a any time we invoke a hook, like
we'll send, we send invocations to event bridge,
you can route it to wherever you want. This is how we're implementing
this under the hood for control tower,
um, but also,
um,
we, so you can see.
Uh, like,
we've launched, uh, this new
screen, basically. I don't know why
I turn off results. Basically you can see
all the invocations that happen in this particular
account and see like
whether they passed or failed and like
what the validation error was the same
for the exact reason of like it's actually really difficult
without something like this to see like the impact
that a worn hook is having.
Um, yeah, so, and observability
is sort of like the next
is observability in
organizations more integrations is sort
of like the next set of features that Hooks is like really
like diving into,
um, but yeah.
Cool.
Any other questions?
Cool. Remember to like and subscribe. I mean, fill
out your survey on your app, um, for this
session if you give us great reviews they give us raises.
If not, they put us back in the pen. So,
uh, yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.